question de la fiscalité qui a été posée
aussi sur la taxe carbone
or la taxe carbone à un principe très
simple je taxe plus l'énergie jeu des
taxes le travail c'est très simple le
travail ne fait pas de changement
climatique et il permet de résoudre le
chômage le carbone et importer fout en
l'air la balance commerciale et font
leur le climat je déplace la fiscalité
c'est aussi simple que ça il s'agit pas
d'en faire quelque chose de punitif il
s'agit d'en faire de quelque chose qui
guident kids id alors bah oui c'est
exactement comme un élève vous lui dites
pas que en une semaine après six ans il
doit être capable de rentrer dans une
école d'ingénieurs lui il a 20 ans pour
ça donc le lacet exactement pas ou pour
apprendre un métier plus généralement là
c'est exactement pareil il s'agit de
donner un cadre et une visibilité
il se trouve que mon boulot consiste à
essayer de soutirer à des gens qui n'en
n'ont pas très envie de l'argent pour
réfléchir à leur avenir ils s'appellent
les affreuses industriels que fait un
affreux industriel ou un affreux
gestionnaire d'entreprise quand il à
réfléchir à l'avenir
il regarde où sont les certitudes dans
l'avenir qu'on lui propose et si dans
les certitudes il n'ya pas le fait que
l'énergie qu'il consomme va lui coûter
de plus en plus cher il ne fait pas les
investissements correspondants or
l'énergie
vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure c'est le
sens de systèmes qui sont extrêmement
rigides qui sont extrêmement rigides
donc ça le problème énergétique et ça a
été dit aussi se résout par les
investissements essentiellement c'est
monstrueusement capitalistique de faire
de l'efficacité énergétique
monstrueusement capitalistique faut
changer des procédés industriels il faut
changer des bâtiments il faut changer
les infrastructures de transport il n'y
a rien de plus que changer les bateaux
il n'y a rien de plus capitalistiques
que l'efficacité énergétique donc si on
ne donne
hors désinvestissements vous avez besoin
de visibilité pour avoir envie de les
faire
donc si on ne donne pas un cadre de
visibilité à l'économie sur le prix sur
les externalités de l'inconvénient et ça
renvoie à la finitude du monde faut
mettre ça sous forme d'externalités dans
l'économie mais ça fait pas un projet de
société
c'est un outil si on ne donne pas un
prix aux externalités dans lequel
industrielle de la visibilité à ce
moment il reste assis sur sa chaise il
reste assis sur sa chaise et c'est très
exactement pareil pour les particuliers
regardez la manière dont le différentiel
essence gazole à déformer le parc
automobile en france en trente ou
quarante ans ça joue un rôle majeur à
long terme
ce genre de signaux ça joue un rôle à
court terme jamais à long terme
ça joue un rôle évidemment c'est toute
la difficulté du métier que vous faites
vous êtes jugés sur des résultats à
trois ans quand le remède que vous
proposez vos propos et par an produira
et c'est pour ça que je disais si on ne
compte pas dans la population des
consensus sur ce genre de sujet qui
dépasse les clivages partisans
on aura le bordel excusez moi on aura le
bordel